welcome to hari sadhus the China where
we discussed the latest techniques and
delve into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at whether you
should buy the 8700 K right now or maybe
wait for the 9700 cape or 8086 cape
which are both coming up in the imminent
future but before we delve into that
make sure to hit that subscribe button
if you guys would like to stay updated
with the latest tech news related to
gaming and pcs so starting off let's
take a look at the performance of each
of these chips because if the
performance isn't good then there's no
point in waiting for them anyways the
80s in number K has 6 cores and twelve
threads as tow megabytes of l3 cache and
its base frequency is 3.7 gigahertz
it's a boost frequency is four point
seven Hertz and this TDP is 95 watts
next up the 8086 K is pretty much
identical to the 87 RK it also has six
cores and twelve threads and tall
megabytes of l3 cache they even has a
TDP of 95 watts the only difference is
that its base frequency as porky Hertz
and its max frequency as fiving Hertz so
as you guys can see it's bass and boost
or 300 megahertz faster than the 8700 K
finally asked for the 9700 K
unfortunately we don't really know the
technical details of this chip yet but
it's still quite a while away however
what we do know is that it is going to
have eight cores and 16 threads and we
can safely assume that Intel does not
want to be beat out by AMD's rise at
7:20 700 X so the 2700 X is also an 8
core 16 thread CPU and it's base
frequency is 3.7 gigahertz and is Boost
frequency is four point three five years
so based off that I'm quite sure that
Intel will offer more than what AMD has
to offer so we can safely expect around
three point eight gig Hertz or three
point seven years base frequency for the
ninety seven order K and it's Boost
frequency will probably be four point
four or four point five units users can
probably overclock even to four point
seven or 4 put AQ Hertz and if you're
lucky maybe even five but definitely at
least four point seven or four point
eight so that's how the performance of
those
look but how much will it cost well
first off the MSRP of the 8200 K is
three hundred and sixty dollars and a
good Z 370 motherboard will cost you
around 120 to 180 dollars so the
eighties of RK with its motherboard will
cost around five hundred dollars more or
less
next up as for the 8086 k we don't have
a specific price point yet but what we
do know is that it will not cost over
four hundred pounds which is over five
hundred and thirty dollars so maybe we
can expect around five hundred dollars
or 450 others somewhere in that range
and the motherboard will probably cost
around the same at 120 to 180 dollars so
you can expect to spend around six
hundred to six hundred and fifty dollars
for the motherboard and the 8086 k
finally asks for the 9700 K at this
point it's really all speculation but
for Intel to be even remotely
competitive with AMD who has their
octa-core processor priced at $319 with
this CPU cool that's actually good Indo
would have to price the 9700 cake at at
least $500 they can't really go above
that or really doesn't make any sense to
buy the 90s anymore okay so that's
probably where Intel priced at $450 to
$500 ask for the motherboard the
motherboard for the Z 390 chipset will
probably be more expensive than the Z
370 chipset low-poly would want us
around 150 to $200 so the 9700 cave with
its motherboard will probably cost
around $700 more or less so that's how
the pricing situation looks for those
three chips the 8700 K will cost around
500 or so to the 8086 K will cost around
600 650
and finally 9700 K will cost $700 so the
performance looks great now and even the
price could be acceptable for many of
you guys but when exactly are these new
chips coming out well first of all day t
similar decay is already out so you can
go buy one right now as for the 8086 k
we are expecting that pre-ordering will
start on June 8th
finally as for the 9700 Cade that's not
going to come out for a couple of months
and it's expected to come out in rot
October or the fourth quarter of this
year so it's toke a couple of months
away so that's all the technical details
for all those chips but I don't think
this video can be complete without
discussing the Rison 720 700 X because
the value that it provides to just
unbeatable it gives you eight cores and
16 threads with the base frequency of
three point seven errors and the max
frequency of four point three five
gigahertz all what's a great stock
cooler for just three hundred and ninety
dollars on top of this the motherboards
that go along with the rise in 720 700 X
are much cheaper and you can even get a
good B series motherboard for around
$100 so it's a lot cheaper and AMD may
even come out with the 2800 X so all you
guys who want even more performance you
may want to consider waiting for that as
well so now that we got all that out of
the way here's what I think
and who should buy each chip here if you
want the best gaming CPU available right
now then you should buy the 8700 k if
you want a novelty chip that provides
more than just performance and has more
significance then you may want to
consider the 8086 k if you want the best
CPU available on the mainstream platform
and you are willing to wait a couple of
months then the 9700 K is definitely
worth waiting for
please it is going to be an absolute
monster finally however if you want a
great CPU cords unbeatable price that is
really good at a variety of tasks then
the Rison 720 700 X is definitely the
best option available right now but
that's just what I think what do you
guys think do you guys think that the
8086 K is completely pointless and it
doesn't really make sense to buy or can
you just not wait for a 9700 kid come on
already make sure to post down in the
comments below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments and
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this view then make sure
drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time bye
[Music]